ça fait un moment je pense à faire cette
vidéo déjà parce que 9 fois sur 10 quand
je vous croise dans la vraie vie vous
parler de mon tatouage et en plus c'est
toujours plus ou moins les mêmes
questions qui reviennent donc c'est pas
que ça me dérange c'est juste que voilà
je me suis dit je vous l'avais promis en
plus on va faire une faq comme ça je
vais répondre à toutes ces questions là
une bonne fois pour toutes
et oui je vous laisse faire toutes les
blagues que vous voulez sur faq
je voulais là c'est cadeau
[Musique]
allez encore pas de temps on commence
directement par la première question
alors cela de loin c'est vraiment celle
qu'on me pose neuf fois sur dix presque
presque à tous les coups
alors je pars du principe que vous
parler de mon tatouage parce que cyril
hanouna
personnellement je ne connais pas donc
on va parler de mon tatouage
en général quand on pose cette question
je réponds avec une pirouette genre il
va un peu trop bien à mon goût et puis
j'explique après que ben il commence à
partir mais que c'est un excellent vous
répondre vraiment à la question là au
jour d'aujourd'hui ce qui est une
expression qui ne veut rien dire donc je
veux dire aujourd'hui au moment où je
vous parle il a commencé à partir je
pense que les choses se sont un petit
peu accéléré avec les dernières séances
de pico sûr ça reste très long je pense
qu'on n'est pas encore au bout du chemin
mais ça va mieux donc ce que je vous
adresse là c'est un message d'espoir
ensuite voilà c'est aujourd'hui on sait
pas comment ça va évoluer dans les jours
qui viennent
donc il va un peu moins bien lui et du
coup moi je vais un peu mieux après
entre nous et si vraiment vous voulez
des nouvelles
vous pouvez juste regarder les vidéos de
ce genre post quand même très
régulièrement sur l'avancement des
travaux
donc je vous en donne pas je je vous
informe juste oui on me demande ça très
très souvent dans la rue dans des bars
des concerts vraiment dans nos
supermarchés ça m'est déjà arrivé et des
gens de tous les styles de tous les âges
vraiment il n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas
de règle absolue donc la règle à tous
les gens sont en général assez déçu
quand je réponds non parce que la
réponse c'est non je suis désolé
alors je sais bien ça peut vous paraître
bizarre parce que après tout mes fesses
tout le monde les a vues sur youtube
mais alors mettez-vous deux secondes à
ma place entre eux filmer ses fesses
chez soi sous l'angle qu'on veut douala
de façon à respecter un petit peu la
pudeur machin etc mettre ça sur youtube
et faire la démarche de baisser son froc
dans un lieu public où il ya vraiment
directement plein de regards qui se
braquent sur toi dont toute une partie
qui ne savent absolument pas de quoi il
s'agit c'est quand même pas la même
c'est quand même
je dirais même que potentiellement c'est
répréhensible au regard de la loi de se
dénuder dans un lieu public
donc non je ne préfère pas alors du coup
vraiment même réponse que précédemment
alors je vous refais un petit peu le
pitch de la première vidéo la vidéo sur
le tatouage
l'idée c'est que au départ je pense me
faire tatouer le visage de l'ennemi
le chanteur de moteur est donc dieu et à
la fin de la vidéo
je découvre qu'en fait on m'a tatouer le
visage de cyril hanouna donc
l'antéchrist
voilà l'idée c'est ça c'était de trouver
le portrait d'une personne que je ne
veux vraiment pas avoir sur moi pour
justifier le fait que j'enchaîne
directement avec les vidéos sur le
détatouage sur le laser parce que j'ai
très envie de me faire retirer voilà
c'était ça c'était ça l'idée
alors fun fact au départ ça devait être
un portrait de qui ne savaient qu'ils
devaient j'avais même fait faire le
dessin par mon frère qu'elle a fait
aussi le dessin de d'hanouna j'avais
envoyé le dessin au tatoueur j'avais
pris rendez vous etc
et deux jours avant illumination
nocturne je me réveille en sueur et je
me dis non
hanouna hanouna c'est vraiment parce que
c'est le truc que je veux vraiment pas
gardé sur moi donc un quine vu en vrai
vous sa musique n'est pas c'est pas mon
truc
thomas personne mais lui j'ai rien à lui
reprocher donc non donc voilà que nous
alors ça c'est une vraie bonne question
il ya plusieurs raisons à ça d'abord
parce que c'est la partie de mon corps
que les gens voient le moins souvent un
à part quelques-uns de mes proches mon
médecin
2 3 type à la salle de sports
globalement c'est quelque chose qui est
relativement dissimulé donc c'est
moindre mal ensuite parce que je savais
qu'après laser il fallait pas d'exposer
le la peau au soleil
je savais que l'été allait arriver assez
vite parce que je me doutais qu'il y
aura plusieurs séances
et voilà je n'avais pas envie de passer
un été galère à cacher une partie de mon
corps du soleil a tout pris ma chance et
a donc là il se trouve que c'est une
partie de mon corps qui globalement voit
assez peu le soleil donc donc c'était
cool et puis j'avoue mais c'est marrant
aussi c'est une autre raison ça les
fesses c'est vraiment une question qu'on
me pose assez régulièrement un plutôt
dans les commentaires vous d'un très
bien mais je réponds que je réponde
alors déjà je propose qu'on reste
courtois et respectueux 1 parce que l'on
n'est pas dans tpm b et donc les
explications sur la démarche qui me vaut
d'éventuellement de passer pour un con
moi une idée c'était de faire une vidéo
sur le tatouage dans les conditions de
la réalité et de faire une vidéo sur le
détatouage j'aurais pu me contenter
d'aller prendre des infos là où il y en
avait c'est à dire à 95% sur les sites
des centres de détatouage ou sur ceux
des fabricants de laser donc on est
d'accord que ça aurait été peu objectif
et ça aurait même été franchement fossé
comme vidéo donc je me suis dit je vais
faire une vidéo en me mettant dans les
conditions de la réalité c'est à dire en
me faisant tatouer un tatouage comme
n'importe qui peut le faire chez un vrai
at war et en me faisant des tatoués pour
voir vraiment comment ça fonctionne et
en utilisant les moyens qui sont
utilisés par tout le monde voilà ça
c'était l'idée de départ c'était la
démarche je peux comprendre que ce soit
une démarche que des gens ne comprennent
pas alors à près de là à en venir à laon
ur alors si j'étais mal poli comme eux
je leur dirai écoute c'est mon cul donc
occupe-toi du tien mais comme moi je
suis un garçon poli je leur dirai juste
écoute c'est mon choix écoutez
franchement non je suis d'abord je
savais depuis le début il y avait un
risque que ça marche pas très bien où
que ça marche pas du tout donc j'ai fait
ça en connaissance de cause je suis pas
inconsciente je ne suis pas à jeter dans
le vide sans conscience du danger
donc voilà le fait est que justement je
voulais vérifier si ça marchait aussi
bien que ce qu'on disait est le seul
moyen que jamais de le faire de façon
concrète c'était de me coller moi même
donc je me suis lancée en ayant
conscience des risques
10 trouvent que voilà ça prend beaucoup
plus longtemps que ce que je pensais
mais du coup voilà pédagogiquement c'est
intéressant
oui il ya des bills à des vraies infos
dans ce que je fais donc voilà ce que je
sais pas c'est pas dramatique ce qui
m'arrive ça reste mes fesses donc c'est
pas un truc non plus pas comme si je
m'étais faite à tous sur le visage
donc non pas de pas de regrets qui dit
moins d'encre encore une fois le l'idée
de départ c'était de voir comment ça
s'en va un vrai tatouage fait chez un
vrai pro l'idée ce n'est pas de me faire
un p'tit truc facile à retirer ça aurait
eu aucun sens donc voilà alors quand
même je me suis fait un gros tatouage
mais c'est de l'encré noire donc pas de
couleurs qui sont plus difficiles à
faire partir ça même les centres de
tatouage de même fabricant de lasers le
dise
et puis c'est que du tracé il n'ya pas
de nombre de gros à plat de noirs qui
sont galère à faire partir tu pas non
plus hein c'est pas du mien car elle
alors j'ai fait le calcul pour l'instant
encore une fois l'heure où je vous parle
mais si vous regardez cette vidéo dans
six mois ça aura augmenté j'ai fait
cette séance de tus which donc le
premier à 150 euros et j'ai fait cinq
séances de pick au jour à 300 euros donc
au total ça fait de 1550 euros un rien
de chasser une vraie info en fait
c'est pour les gens qui envisagerait de
se lancer
c'est une vraie information c'est un
budget il ya un gros budget et c'est pas
fini
en plus donc voilà mais en ce qui me
concerne en toute transparence
j'ai pas payer cette somme j'ai des
accords avec les centres avec mon
network et c'est donc tout ça ne sort
pas de ma poche vous inquiétez pas je me
suis par une grille je sais que je peux
le faire recouvrir je suis au courant de
ça mais le but là de la démarche c'est
pas de faire disparaître juste le
tatouage
sinon je l'aurais pas fait en fait
j'aurais fait un modèle qui me plaît à
la limite directement là on aurait gagné
du temps accessoirement je l'aurais pas
fait à cet endroit non plus parce que le
projet s'était pas d'avoir un tatouage
tel qu'il soit sur le cul vraiment
c'était pas mon idée en fait encore une
fois la démarche c'est de tester le
détatouage au laser c'est de voir un
tatouage classique
combien de temps ça prend à faire partir
combien de séances il faut et comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure
combien ça coûte au final voilà donc
c'est ça le truc donc moi tant que je
n'ai pas eu sa peau je continue et s'il
ya un moment on dit bon bah voilà
là on n'aura pas mieux alors ça partira
pas plus que ça évidemment à ce moment
là je viserai mais pour l'instant non
l'idée c'est de tester le laser jusqu'au
bout voilà donc non pas de recours
voilà j'espère que j'ai répondu à un
maximum de vos questions si vous en avez
d'autres vous continuez à me les poser
et puis on en reparlera un autre un
autre moment en attendant on se retrouve
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos
d'ici là mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien
[Musique]